arriesgar la vida para volver a casa los
que regresan a este pequeño pueblo de
las afueras de kiev deben firmar una
renuncia en la que reconocen los
peligros
firmamos los papeles en la comisaría que
dicen que si se produce una explosión
no haremos responsables a los soldados
el ejército está tratando de limpiar la
zona de minas para los tantos que desean
regresar
en el curso
si los soldados rusos colocan trampas
explosivas en anillos joyas y collares
cavani ponen explosivos lo mismo hacen
con los juguetes de los niños y hasta
con los cuerpos de sus propios soldados
ponen trampas en cualquier cosa que
llame la atención cosas que pueden ser
recogidas
es
para evitar las explosiones los
residentes han desarrollado técnicas
caseras como este panadero que volvió a
casa para recuperar lo que quedaba de su
negocio y espero que haya deslizado una
cuerda con un gancho tienes que lanzarla
y tirar de ella en el suelo si no
explota nada puedes avanzar otros cinco
metros lo mismo con la puerta usas el
gancho para abrirla así es la vida ahora
otras desde el comienzo de la guerra el
servicio de desminado ucraniano ya ha
retirado más de 48 mil municiones según
el servicio estatal de emergencias de
ucrania la mitad del territorio del país
necesitará desminado